Well,
it seems as if there's a really big
switch between about five and six.
And of course it's funny because in our
culture we say we talk about that age
group is preschoolers versus school aged
children.
Of course school is a very recent
invention.
But if you look across lots of cultures,
something happens around you know,
around six.
So the babies say,
uh,
we'll move from the mother's quarters to
the children's quarters or they babies
used to,
uh,
kids used to start becoming apprentice
being being apprentices when they were
about seven.
And you know,
sort of losing your first tooth seems to
be a big marker of this transition.
And I think what happens is that that
kind of transition,
and of course it's,
you know,
starting at four or five and then
continuing is really a transition from a
creature that's mostly designed to do
this very broad based learning to a
creature that's starting to develop the
specific skills that are going to be
important as an adult.
So by the time you get to a seven,
eight,
nine year olds,
they can actually work.
I mean they can actually do things that
can actually do things that are
productive and helpful.
Um,
and they're starting to get those
narrow,
more narrow,
uh,
maybe I think to say it's not just more
narrow but more specialized.
So in some cultures,
our culture really values are very,
very narrow focus of attention.
That's what we teach kids to do in
school.
In other cultures what they'll do is
teach kids to do things like shift
attention from one thing to another very
easily.
The,
yeah.
Um,
the important thing is that in all
cultures you go from this early very,
very wide ranging attention,
which is like infants to,
and here's the attentional strategy that
is important to do.
The things that you need to do in,
in this culture.
And sometimes it can be the narrow focus
that we have in,
in our culture,
but other cultures,
as I say it might be if you're a hunter
for instance,
it might be how to pay attention to lots
of different things at once in order to
hunt more effectively.
Show me how they can,
you know,
what can we do to make them do it
better?
Um,
and I'm afraid,
I think the answer to it is pretty
boring,
which is a,
have lots of caregivers around who loved
them a lot and have lots of stuff around
for them to play with and let them play
without worrying too much about whether
they're getting academic skills or
they're making a mass.
One of the things I say is from an
evolutionary point of view,
probably the ideal rich environment for
a baby has,
includes more mud,
livestock and relatives than most of us
could tolerate,
uh,
nowadays.
But I think,
you know,
some pigs,
some,
a lot of dirt and a bunch of uncles and
cousins,
that's probably pretty good environment
for babies to grow up and,
but if you can't manage that,
then a lot of cardboard boxes,
you know,
being plants,
goldfish,
um,
the kinds of things you see in fact
sandboxes,
the kind of things you see and really
great.
But I,
you know,
when I say that it sounds very boring
and banal,
but here's,
is one important thing.
We know from the science,
it's the thing that kids learn from most
is other people and particularly other
people who are dedicated to taking care
of them.
And in most places and times in human
history,
babies have had not just one person,
but lots of people around who were
really paying attention to them around
dedicated to them,
care to them.
We're related to them.
Um,
uh,
and I think the big shift in our culture
is the isolation in which many children
are growing up.
So in fuck,
if we really wanted to make babies
smarter,
what we would do is make sure that 20%
of them aren't growing up in poverty.
Make sure that even middle class parents
aren't so insane because they're working
so hard that they can't spend time with
their kids.
Make sure that preschool workers are
actually paid more than dog catchers.
So the thing that's most important is
having people who are involved and
engaged with the kids and also are not
stressed and can be involved with them.
And that's actually not boring and
Banal.
That actually takes a lot of work to
make that happen.
And it's not something that our society
does very well
[inaudible].